[Music]
what is poppin fan Monday morning
here in Los Angeles what is happening
fresh off a family road trip in San
Diego went to the Padres game tell you
what boy San diegoans know how to drink
they I've never seen so many hammered
people at a baseball game my entire life
it was dicey it was dicey it was a last
minute thing I saw it was opening uh
game for the Padres for the MLB season
and my kids uh do like going to the game
so let's do it like yay we be lying down
there I meet there by the second inning
here's the thing though I and I was
talking to a bunch of people there I'm
trying to think there's so many uh
people that I knew that at the at the
game but I was like man there were so
many fights in the bathroom all those
people are hammered like why everyone's
so hammered San Diego's always like this
the Padre games are always like this
like no the game was supposed to be at
one o'clock because the rain delay they
push it to seven so people have been
just waiting since basically noon
drinking like oh oh that makes sense
that makes sense it looked like The
Purge it was uh it was fun though it was
fun shout out to San Diego
um but thank the fight Gods because you
have a big ass card this Saturday UFC
287 is finally here and it is one hell
of a card worth every bit of your
hard-earned money fam uh we're also
doing a special uh calabas fight
companion you have Brian Callan Cheeto
Vera myself and a very special guest who
I'll announce on Thursday but we have
one hell of a crew for UFC 287 Cal bass
fight campaigning live on thick boy
YouTube Saturday 7 P.M Pacific time so
make sure you tune into that live and if
not you can watch it on Sunday or Monday
as it uploads to YouTube and all your
audio streaming services that is UFC 287
headlined by Alex Pierre and Izzy uh the
rematch there
I would say rematch rematch in the UFC
they fought previously uh twice before
that kickboxing but uh
yeah you got your rematch the whole card
we'll get to the main event in a second
the whole card is pretty tasty the whole
entire card is Stacy you know it's a
good card we got Cynthia calvillo on the
early prelims you have Gerald Merchant
on there
um and then your prelims for ESPN
you got Michelle Waterson Kevin
Kelvin gaslum Chris Curtis and then the
main card kicks off with the young buck
Raul Rosa Jr versus Christian Rodriguez
this is not a uh a walk in the park for
uh Rosa Junior this is not a a gimme
fight this will be by far the toughest
fight of his young uh budding career
um you know Rodriguez is no punk he's no
punk and oh was he ate one yep is he ate
one or eight no he's eight and one oh he
lost his first fight in the UFC against
Jonathan Pierce last or won his last one
with the anaconda choke in the first
round and he was a also unanimous
decision winner on Dana White's
Contender Series so by far the toughest
test for a very young 18 year old with a
long face in Rosa Junior
um my man just facts Spaniard Savage so
Rose is Junior uh he has work cut out
for him he's going to pass the test
though but I don't don't think it's
gonna be easy I bet that thing goes the
decision and I think we see what Rosa
Junior is made out of it's a perfect
test uh where he's at I think being 18
years old kicking off a huge
pay-per-view so the UFC has high hopes
for Rosa Junior man really high hopes
you know the kid's young as hell and uh
he doesn't have a lot of experience and
put him right up there he's born in 2004
which is insane it's so so insane so to
put them right up there uh is a big test
for him and again if this isn't gonna be
a cakewalk if you're a rose a junior fan
this is not a gimme fight this is a
fight where I think it goes to the
judge's scorecards and he wins
um
29-28 I could see uh 30-27 we'll see on
the judges man might go to draw some
[__] but you never know what the
judge is but uh Rosa Junior has his work
cut out for him not an easy fight which
I'm I'm proud of him man good for him
good for the UFC for pushing the kid put
on the main card uh second fight on the
main card you got Kevin Holland this is
a fun fight Kevin Holland Santiago nibio
uh tough fight for your boy ponson nebio
Kevin Hollins no punk man Kevin Holland
is absolutely no punk
um I wouldn't be surprised if Kevin
Holland Clips them and then submits this
guy and now you're dealing with a
dangerous Kevin Holland too because he's
coming off a two-fight uh losing skid
here obviously the homslot loss is uh a
tough one for him did we count that as a
loss so took it based on a three-hour
notice at a catch weight 180 pounds
that's whatever he did the UFC a solid
that's the whole conspiracy thing that
you'll see uh 279 which we don't want to
get into
um and then he lost to one boy Thompson
uh that's fight of the night uh he ended
up shooting in that fight which was
interesting but you got a Kevin Holland
back in a corner can't lose three in a
row three in a row gets a little dicey
for Kevin Holland ponson Nebo is a good
matchup both kind of had a fork in the
road uh I'll take Kevin Hall in this
fight all day with this fork in the road
and then what I think will be your uh
yeah it'll be your fight of the night
will be Rob font versus Adrian Yanez
um fantastic fight I think this should
have been a main event on a fight night
I would like to see these two gentlemen
go five rounds uh it's the first real
test for Yanez who I'm a huge fan of
Love Adriana's uh Rob font big fan of
Rob fun as well
um Adrian undefeated in the UFC this kid
is a little Banshee fighting out of I
think San Antonio he's out of Texas but
uh you know he hasn't faced uh any real
big test yet and Rob font is that test
they're trying to see where where he
lines up at Rob coming off some tough
some tough ones the Marlin Vera the
Cheeto fight right he took all the
punches of the face Jose Jose Aldo was a
tough one
um and his win over Marlon Marius
there was so much damage done that fight
you wonder how much more he can fight
with that style
um you know but he beat Marlon then he
beat Cody garbrandt Jose Aldo was a
tough one the Marlin bear was an awful
fight for him with his face
um so I guess this is a matter of you
know changing of the guards here you got
the Young Buck and Adrian Yanez versus
the old Salty Dog from the New England
cartel in Rob font it's a big step up
for Adriana's and I think he passed
passes this test in flying colors I
think your fight of the night I do think
it goes to the judge's decision so I
think your rose of Junior wins decision
Kevin Holland uh via finished submission
and uh Adrian Yanez via decision as well
that leads us to the co-main event
Gilbert Burns Jorge mazwidal
oh boy interesting one right uh for
Gilbert burns
his stock went through the freaking roof
right one with his uh uh hamzat fight
through the roof and then what he did
Neil magnney was just uh disrespectful
in the first round in Brazil
um you know
for Gilbert Burns you know with this
this division it they don't really know
what to do but I do think this is them
rewarding Gilbert Burns because it's one
of those money fights Jory mosvilla is
one of those money Fighters where it
doesn't matter how many fights he's won
or lost we're always going to tune in
he's just crossed over into there's a
few guys that cross over that and you're
talking about you know a guy in
um mazdal you know who's lost his last
three fights you know he lost three
fights he's lost five out of his last
eight
um lost dami Maya what decision that one
Stacy uh one boy Thompson he beat there
until Mary starts there until in London
which is what kicked off the whole kind
of Phenom and mozvidol even though if
you're hardcore you've been following
this guy since he was fighting with
Kimbo Slice in backyards in Dade County
Miami
um but the Darren tell one kicked it off
then the bed asking one put him in
another Stratosphere with the neat
flying knee which one of the greatest
knockouts of all time fastest knockout
in UFC history let's take a little break
here this episode of the shop show is
brought to you by the one the only the
faithful on it listen your boy's busy
that's by Design I like to have a lot of
my plate and my friends at on it helped
me maintain focus in order to function
and stay in a high Zone they helped me
out with a little Alpha Brain I take the
Black Label the highly concentrated uh
Black Label Alpha Brain promotes
attention focus Alpha Brain helps
support cognitive functions include
memory mental speed and focus yeah I
need help with all that stuff right uh
what are the benefits the Alpha Brain
you asked well I'm gonna tell you the
benefits of Alpha Brain regular but
think of all this with a little turbo
for your brain piece all right AIDS and
mental processing caffeine free helps
with the flow State promotes focus and
supports Memory Alpha Brain can help you
remember names and places like your
girlfriend where she lives all sorts of
phone numbers all right think more
clearly under stress react more quickly
if you can't use any of that well I
guess you don't need to try the best
nootropic on planet Earth they've sold
over a million bottles on it also offers
fitness equipment the best of the best
kettlebells steel Club maces sandbags
yoga mats you need better nutrition say
less Anna has MCT oil protein protein
bars protein powders we got it all they
offer on-demand workouts if your thick
ass needs to get in shape you don't need
to go to gym do it from the comfort of
your living room they have streaming
Fitness right we got you go to audit.com
shop receive 10 off everything including
Alpha Brain black alpha bring instant
Alpha Brain Focus shot regular Alpha
Brain we got it all workout gear workout
streaming Fitness he saved himself
everything go to audit.com shop for 10
off all right fam this next one I only
recommend products that I actually use
and this is this next product is one I
actually use I reached out to them to be
part of the program I'll talk about my
friend that happy hippo it's the best
cradle on the planet it's the only trade
him that I trust all right I use it when
I'm on stage when I'm doing podcasts so
I'm chilling whatever I'm looking for
your boys on that Kratom but not just
from anybody from Happy Hippo I used a
shot I always have it here I use the
sour apple the butterscotch I preferred
these days right now but if you don't
like shots they have gummies they have
powders they got it all and you missed
out because last week the other 10-year
anniversary they were given 30 off now
it's back to 20 off all right if you
want to try the best trade them the my
Hidden Gem my Limitless bill you gotta
go to happyhippo.com promo code is
thick23 you get 20
for life right Senator friend family
co-workers whoever you want try Kratom
that you can actually trust that
actually worked in whatever form you use
it in whether it's a shot whether it's
the gummies whether it's the powder I
got you covered go to happyhippo.com
promo code is thick with three C's
t-h-i-c-c-c 23 for 20 off now let's get
back to the program and then the Nate
Dia stop it she actually absolutely beat
the brakes off Nate Diaz on the BMF
title and then after that he got dicey
for him tomorrow Usman come on Usman
Kobe Covington
and be tough to give them a single round
in any of those fights you know so five
out of his last eight uh three fight
losing skid and you guilt get Gilbert
Burns who's coming off uh you know a big
win and then obviously a moral Victory
and a fan victory over hamzat so it is a
tough one for Jorge Mazda I want to say
he's a five to one dog
but he's the money fight and because
he's the dog he'd never count Jory
maswood all out
what what worries me a little bit is
Jorge he's plus 390 right now uh Gilbert
Burns is minus 490 which is insanely a
huge difference
um with Jorge mazvidal
you know because he is you know he's
always been an underdog his entire
career he's always just this dog they
can't count out but what does alarm me a
little bit is a huge hori mosquito fan
is he said this in the news recent I
think it's just a day or two ago he was
the press conference for his big uh
boxing fight over the weekend the game
Brad fighting he said if I lose this
fight I'm done I'm retiring it's like
ooh
it's never good so that means you got
one foot out the door Gilbert Burns has
two feet all the way balls deep in the
UFC fighting game so for Jorge Mazda
he's had a great run man but when I hear
him say ah this If I Lose I'm out like
[__] you know that's trouble that's
trouble fighting a guy against Gilbert
Burns I uh you know I hope Jorge gets it
done man I love Gilbert too but I'm just
a huge Jorge fan so it's a tough one for
him it's a tough one for him but Jorge
is that guy you don't you don't care
wins or losses uh he should be he's a
he's a big fight big fight card guy and
so they gave to him in the co-main event
but we'll we'll see how many he has of
these left especially if he loses he's
talking about retiring I never liked
that when a fighter talks about retiring
say that after the fight don't don't
don't tell us where your mind's at going
into a huge co-main event on UFC 287
that's trouble it always leads to
trouble
um the main event is another barn burner
huh
Alex Pierre Izzy arasania
um you know is he's the best
middleweight we've ever seen but the one
guy that has his number he's his
Achilles heel is a guy named Alex Pierre
who also beat him in kickboxing as well
so his he's never beat him huh because
he's never beat him what's tough here is
you know
I think if we weren't so
I don't say in love but we're definitely
big fans Izzy here at the thick boy
Studios we love Izzy and if someone
let's say you didn't know is he didn't
know Alex and said hey who do you
think's gonna win uh this guy's lost
literally every time he's fought him
um but he's favored to win this fourth
fight that they're gonna go into who
would you bet on him but yeah the guy
beat him every time he's a underdog
probably gonna take the underdog that's
insane
so it's tough to tell because I'm so
biased towards Izzy he's a minus 140. so
I was thinking how they came up with
this minus 140 well again to to kind of
ride on Izzy's nuts here if you look at
the fights I know he lost but if he
didn't get clipped if he didn't get
finished he wins those fights he's won
more rounds
he's been he's had more rounds one than
Alex Piera when they fought you know
these gentlemen have spent numerous
times inside a ring and octagon and for
the majority of the time that they've
spent inside a ringer cage
is he's winning
is he's winning and then Alex Pierre who
could probably find it heavyweight
connects with that Brazilian bomb and
the fight's over
so if you're a betting man which I am if
you're a betting man do you think Izzy
who's been unsuccessful at doing this
for what three fights now especially in
the last one well in MMA he's been
unsuccessful so he's on one do you think
that Izzy can do what he's been doing
and not get clipped
history would say no
how do you guys feel what do you think
Jen
I told you
that as much as I want stop under when I
think it's going to be so beautiful if
he wins because the whole mental thing
to be beaten by someone that many times
right and to finally like conquer him
and you were doing really well but then
obviously there's something in the
mental thing I think somewhere with Izzy
I don't know it's mental I just think
I'll experience it's so damn hard you're
right but even later in the rounds the
guy just hits like a [__] truck
absolutely but for me when I look at it
that's how I feel I feel like there's
like a some sort of block yeah but if
he's able to conquer that and get over
and actually beat uh on this particular
fight it would be such a beautiful
amazing thing but as much as I love Izzy
if I had to bet my like you know what my
life savings on something yeah I I would
have to just bet with the politics yeah
inner piece of [__] I know I don't want
I don't
I know I know I know what that man you
know yeah
okay same thing no I think
hell yeah yeah
he wins of course but that's not how the
yeah that's not how it goes is it I know
yeah I just I'm leaning towards Izzy he
you know here's what's interesting is
let's say as he wins so it's 1-1 in the
UFC
do you run it back you can't right I
don't think this is it dude yeah because
the the division we got to move on we
got to move on
we have to move on you know you just
have to you have to move on here's where
it gets interesting
is again as much we love Izzy here
if let's say Izzy or Alex wins this
fight
your next fight's gonna get be against
Harm's not
I'm listening
name which one of those two gentlemen
beat homside
it'll be so tough super tough I don't
know now you know depending how this
fight goes I think hamzat's scheduled to
get a fight
um at middleweight so they're gonna toss
them maybe a Whitaker or something like
that or vittori
um maybe a Jared Cannon there either way
you gotta you know let I don't think you
can go straight from Hamza who's never
competed for a title even at 170 were
started and then he's never fought at
middleweight at a high level and just
toss him in the main event for a title
shot I think you gotta have him beat a
Whitaker to earn his keep so the rest of
vision's like okay this guy's the real
deal because if you give him Robert
Whittaker and he mops the floor listen
Robert Whittaker would give Piera or
Izzy all they can handle don't get it
twisted Robert Whitaker is a
[__] so you would have to have a
hamzat fighter Robert Whittaker show the
division show the fan base that he can
be this straight Savage at 85 and then
he'd fight the winner of Alex and Izzy
but based off that and I do think Robert
Whittaker is a tougher matchup for uh
hom's lot than Alex Pierre or Izzy by
the way so if he gets by that it's gonna
be tough
the Hamza can be reigning champ for
quite some time
point is is the winner of Saturday's
fight
in all likelihood your prize is fighting
harms at 85 and you're gonna find out
how good he is
you know so I don't again the the reason
went down this road rabbit hole is I
just you you can't do a third fight even
even if it's one and one I don't know I
just I don't see it I don't see it
unless it's uh a judge's decision it's
like super controversial and it's not
really a clear winner you know because
the the thought process there is the
first time they fought is he won the
majority of the rounds got clipped he's
winning the entire yeah the entire fight
when the majority of the rounds so
you're like all right Izzy guy but we
got clip they run it this time let's say
is he
tkosm you wouldn't be like well he won
the first fight until he got clip he
dominate him this time nobody's really
asking for a third time
I just I don't see this happening you no
matter what happens now obviously you're
definitely not gonna do the rematch of
uh Alex wins because he's two enough
makes no sense but even if Izzy wins
this I think it's the last time you see
it I really do and there was that little
you know it's not controversy but you
know Izzy was still standing up when
when the referee stopped up yeah so is
he even said you know I was moving my
head and like I was still in there yeah
so it was kind of like somewhat a slight
they want to see him go out on a shield
I guess which
stoppage but yeah yeah I don't know yeah
but again oh cool you won unless Alex
goes up to heavyweight or I'm sorry
light heavyweight I can't do both I
think that's why that was in like a
blunder there I thought he might as well
go to heavyweight he's so big so huge
yeah he started cutting weight last
December
and gains it up you just picture him
just cutting weight at all hours of the
day that poor guy what he's doing his
body
I wouldn't be surprised this last fight
at at middleweight
yeah because then I'm like hey here's
Hamza enjoy that YouTube Oh neither one
he can really wrestle hilarious here's
hamzat
it's just he's a nightmare for the
nightmare
it'd be cool to see hamzat standing next
to style Bender or Alex just see how
like the the difference in sizes oh dude
yeah if whoever wins hamzat is he would
be my dream fight for this year Alex
Pierre Hamza dream fight for the shoot
that'd be phenomenal phenomenal that
middleweight division needs it man again
it's the changing the guards right now
you know there's a lot of old heads in
there it's you know it's getting chunky
at the top there but yeah I'm excited
for this whole fight card so uh little
let me give you my picks I'm gonna go uh
Rosa Junior via decision Kevin Holland
via submission but I think he Clips him
and then submits him with a rear naked
choke or DARS Rob Fawn Adrian Giannis
I'll take Adrian Yanez uh majority
decision that's your fight of the night
Gilbert Burns Tori masvidal
do I have to pick
I mean listen
if you take my bias out of it my
relationship with those two guys there's
a reason Gilbert Burns is damn near five
to one favorite there you know Jorge
lost last three fights Jorge's talking
about retiring I would have picked Tori
if he didn't mention before we even get
into fight week that he's gonna this is
his last fight if he loses that's a huge
red flag to me so I'll take Gilbert
Burns uh but you guys can be surprised
about the output of hory Mazda on the
heart that Jorge mazuela has this isn't
gonna be a one-sided thing where he just
gets his ass beat
um and then Alex Pierre Izzy oof I'll
take Izzy via decision
cool
are you betting on this fight at all oh
yeah you are yeah oh meme Cowan got like
five G's on Alex and Izzy
oh McDonald shake that old man down too
I mean yeah it's it's a close I bet I
could get Brian to bet on the Rob font
Adrian Giannis fight you don't know who
either of those men are I bet I could
get them or I bet you I get Brian he
doesn't know odds to bet on Gilbert
Burns Tori maswell
but we'll definitely do the we already
made the bed I think we made it on the
fight campaign with Rogan last time
it's a good bet right it's like such a
toss-up when the fights are that close
it's fun and Brian does love boxing a
lot right so I figured he might pick
Adrian but he doesn't know much I'm
guessing about it yeah probably not I
hope no
I'll bring him I'll find kiddo go uh you
can bring him up
yeah it's kind of he knows a lot a lot
of fires but some he just doesn't have
any it's listen if you're not in it I
get it it's tough to keep up like
Rampage too oh yeah whoever name someone
who's not like a huge monkey and like I
have no clue who you're talking about he
just doesn't keep up with it yeah
what else you got dude uh do you want to
cover any of the fights that happened
over this past weekend I mean yeah thick
on thick crime Anthony Pettis Roy Jones
Jr a couple thickies goes a picture of
them real quick they
Roy is looking super thick but uh yeah
pedis was like 200 pounds or something
like that dude I think Chuck I think
it's Chuck Mendenhall said this this is
an insane stat
think about this Roy Jones Jr
in 1993 when UFC one came to Denver
Colorado Roy Jones Jr was 24-0 as a pro
boxer
UFC won Roy Jones Jr's 24-0 2023 he's
the main event Main Event against
Anthony paddes
you know it's just
I mean for pet it's a huge feather in
your cap to beat Roy Jones Jr
if I be Roy Jones I just wouldn't have I
would have only his vintage pictures in
my house I would not have that way in
picture my kids like you beat Roy Jones
I sure did and as kids get older they
just don't know what year it is but you
just have like vintage Roy Jones
highlights playing yeah I beat him yep
first boxing match I've been like holy
[__] like yeah big deal big deal look it
up nah
um so shout out to Anthony Perez he's
want to know I do see a little bit like
you'll see how like I think Jeremy
Stevens Jose Aldo uh I didn't hear of
Pettis or not but they're calling out
you know
um Conor or they're looking for those
big money fights
if you're a Jake Paul fan you like this
I hate to say almost feeder League to
this entertainment boxing Revenue you
know it's like this is just
feeding more
Superstars to for Jake Paul and Logan
Paul and the KSI is the world to fight
because this is who they should be
fighting they shouldn't be fighting real
bot well I don't know why they want to
play in the real boxing game that's a
terrible idea but here like you're
telling me you want to watch Jake Paul
Auntie Pettis
now I'm not saying that I'm in love with
it what I'm saying is there's a huge
Lane for it and I don't hate on it good
for them and get yours fancy Pettis to
you know have the Hall of Fame career
out in the UFC go over to the pfl the
showtime kick over Ben Henderson he's on
a Wheaties box great dude too great
[__] dude and then to have that
career and then now he's making tons of
money fighting Roy Jones Jr could fight
a Jake Paul yeah dude get yours man and
I'll watch I'll pay for it too you know
I'm it's not it's I'm not
shutting the family down me hey we're
ordering pizza and watching this every
weekend if it's every week but once
every three months every four months I'm
into it there's a lane for it but all
this is like when I see this stuff like
the game bread stuff what he's doing I
love that Jorge is doing this Jorge has
his tequila he has his fight League his
promotionally you know he's doing a lot
of cool [__] man outside that octagon I
celebrate all of it man we should all
support each other right so I love all
that stuff but what I see here is like
oh this is kind of a feeder League to
get to those big boys you know the
Auntie Pettis Conor fight in boxing the
Anthony Pettis Logan Paul Jake Paul
fight especially Anthony Pettis at that
weight yeah you're making a fight Jake
you should probably have to cut some
pounds no I can lie to you uh so the the
Jeremy Stevens the Jose Aldos you know
all that I see him like yo this is just
Jake and Logan can fight for the next
five years at this rate if they keep
putting these guys out like this
it's good business there's a there's a
lane for it that's all I'm saying
there's Lane for it that's the whole
card good for him uh real quick on this
too though when I bought this so I
bought it on my laptop I try to buy it
on my TV I have an Insignia Fire TV like
the Amazon Fire TV yes
it's changing so but then I was like
they said that you can buy the app there
so I tried to download the app and it
says unavailable the app is unavailable
so I'm like that sucks so download on my
laptop and then I try to cast it this so
you can cast it to your TV right AirPlay
so I casted it everything worked the
chat room and everything except for the
video wouldn't play so then I'm like
maybe I have a you know my i o my system
is older so I went to my phone and my
iPad I tried every possible way and it
wouldn't work I could only watch it on
my laptop at the bottom and I couldn't
fast forward I was sorry I couldn't
rewind when I saw something I couldn't
pause you know all that stuff which hey
bro it's the first one be cool man I
don't know how old that pay-per-view app
is but it was it for me it was shitty
I'm wondering if other people felt the
same way why did I think it was on a UFC
fight pass it was on UFC Fight Pass too
but I don't have five pass oh
ESPN plus that's all I have oh yeah I
think if you have fight bash you can
stream it on I'm not gonna buy a fat
person yeah yeah because they fired me
oh does it fired me yes exactly yeah
what else you got uh so there's other
fights real quick we'll just touch on a
pfl uh Brendan lock name beat Marlon
Morris who's had like a it's a tough
ride for him right now yeah he's been
losing a ton of fights
um shout out to Brendan Wilkinson beat
Tiago Santos
and then we'll move over to this real
quick
uh cat's gonna but there's a Bellator so
she won against Leo McCourt unanimous
decision and now her next opponent most
likely will have what should be the
agent though now oh [__] well yeah well
likely it's going to be Chris cyborg
though yeah yeah
and then the biggest episode of the
weekend uh San Diego State
um
in that last second shot they're about
to get their ass whooped I hope not by
UConn tonight but um
uh that was it Joey Davis J Davis go
back to the fight card he was like a
minus 3 000 or some [__] Joey Davis Joey
Davis I mean it's uh it has to be one of
the biggest upsets in a hot [__]
second he's in Bellator since Tommy Fury
beat Jake Paul what
oh Jeff writing versus Joey Davis yeah
Joey Davis I mean you're talking about
wrestling Legend dude pedigree I'm
telling you he must have been a minus
five thousand
so that's his NCAA yeah dude gold gold
gold gold
isn't that crazy
such a Savage he took some time off and
then uh
yeah oh he's a dude so he took a two and
a half year layoff
uh made his returns over the weekend
despite being a ready for this a 14-1
favorite
that's tough
but it's a tough pill to swallow we'll
be all right though but that's the
beauty of MMA too you never know yeah
uh the biggest news I guess basically
for
the MMA world is an Endeavor who owns
UFC
uh they're they're doing a deal with WWE
and then I guess they're teaming them up
to create a new company that's going to
be publicly traded so it's gonna be
worth those [__] so see the lines will
get a little blurry if you're a hardcore
fan you liked you know the the old UFC
days you know the UFC 99s and 100s those
days are gone we're getting closer to
the weird Matrix where WWE and this UFC
World slowly combining they've already
crossed paths a little bit and uh
it makes sense because you know Dana
White don't get me wrong he deserves
everything he's earned there with the
UFC but his business plan it's not like
he invented the iPhone his business plan
is the exact same as Vince McMahon's
they were the first to do it so he's
taking a page out of their book anything
you see WWE does the UFC does so for
endeavor who owns the UFC to be like
well why don't we buy the the big dog
you know
um
so the deal transaction value is UFC up
that's the crazy part too hold up here
the deal transaction values UFC at 12.1
billion an impressive increase over 4
billion never paid for the pros 2016.
but the WWE is valued at 9.3 billion
you're telling me UFC is more valuable
in WWE according to this yes
what it's insane right
I think once they do this purchase they
have to like show the stats of whatever
the values are so that's when it was of
you know that's when this news came out
that it was actually valued here's where
it gets dicey here's where it gets
really dicey so
explain this
in 2016 the UFC was purchased for what
uh
8 billion or something like that I don't
know four four so four billion they're
worth 12 billion now
so that's eight more billion dollars
that they've been that they're worth
have you seen a huge increase in fighter
pay no that's the problem
so if I'm the fighter it doesn't matter
it you know it doesn't [__] matter I
beat this dead horse so many times if
you're an agent and you have a roster of
badasses and you read this news and go
the UFC's worth eight more billion
dollars when we sign our contract four
years ago
hey man pay us more money what leg does
the UFC have to stand on what argument
do they have with like we just can't why
not
don't want to you know it's like what
what's the art what what argument is
there if you're a fighter and you're
listening this ask your manager agent
hey hey man why can't we get more money
I would love an explanation of why you
can't now if you say it's the market
value
exactly it's the market value they've
gone up
eight billion dollars and if they go
well you're paying from the last time
you signed has gone up 10 percent
no I get that but that's 10 of 80 grand
so I'm making whatever 88 000 now
they've gone up how many times
eight more billion dollars and you're
giving a 10 raise
or how about see this it's good and bad
that's coming to light because also
the UFC per fight for bonuses is fifty
thousand dollars it used to be a hundred
thousand they've gone lower and they've
made more
everyone's cool with this we're all okay
with this
yeah you're not gonna do [__]
ain't gonna do [__] you know that Cobalt
in your phone phone is terrible we ain't
doing [__] we all use iPhones
ain't doing [__] if I have that Cobalt
[__] battery in your Tesla's horrible
for people it's slave labor you ain't
doing [__] you know the ufcs are getting
paid pennies the fighters getting paid
pennies
now for WME
for William our uh for endeavor I mean
dude there's just
it's it it gets it's dicey it gets dicey
I know I keep saying dice in this
episode because it is it gets dicey
because the owners of the UFC which is a
legit Sports organization also owns the
WWE which listen it's hard work I get it
but it's not real Sports
it's just but to blur those lines is
already for the common fan who's not
huge in the UFC and kind of knows about
WB and you mix those it makes them water
even murky murky murky you know and you
already have you know Ron Rousey's over
there you have Brock over there now only
how much he's you don't think Brock's
gonna fight John Jones after this deal
you don't think Brock Lesnar is gonna
Mosey on over and now
Endeavor owns both of them
easy deal to get done
easy deal to get done also Vince McMahon
shave your mustache
shave it right now
shave your mustache and do less trt
right now sir go to them
he looks like Wario
is it that one right there yeah oh dude
gosh
look at that
that's me you know that 20 years I'm
slowly morphing into that but my ears
won't be that big because my cauliflower
I'm slowly morphing to that that is uh
that's Broadway's live action
Wario if Super Mario's was on Broadway
that's Wario
that's who that is
holler yeah same person pretty much
trt'd up same person
I didn't know he did that so he's dying
his hair and his I don't know he did
that either
also here's something else for you guys
to chew on silly [__] how about this
how about this dude think of the current
climate we're in you know I mean I'm all
against the canceled culture I don't
like any of that [__]
but what did it tell you if you're big
enough you're powerful enough and good
for them they've earned every bit of it
and I'm not saying any actions should be
taken I'm just saying how weird is it
that there's been people accused of way
less who lost their careers got [__]
over
there's video of Dana salt and his wife
there's endless accounts and Witnesses
and the guy had to step down from his
position as the chairman of WWE there's
tons of legit evidence but then I have
friends who've been canceled for way
less
these men have gotten bigger they've
made more money
in Denver Endeavor owns Hollywood so
Hollywood wants to sit on their high
horse and say this guy can't perform
here or this guy can't be in this movie
that but these two are okay
[__] you
did
they've gotten bigger dude
that's how weird Hollywood is how
strange is that like legit anybody
else's royally [__] eating cup of
noodles every night jacking off the
Undertaker if you're Vince McMahon and
you're not Vince McMahon you know what
I'm saying if you look like Wario and
you didn't have that power you're
jacking off the mankind old reruns not
him
he sold his company for whatever it was
seven six billion dollars
and he's still gonna be the face of it
Dana's gotten bigger and I'm not saying
they should do anything in these men I
don't know enough about it I don't know
enough about it what I'm saying is is if
you're gonna keep that energy with
certain people keep it across the board
don't be so wishy-washy because these
guys have a lot of money that's all I'm
saying it's very strange to me that's
Hollywood a nutshell what else you got
chin
Vince I know you're a huge fan of the
show
shave that mustache and stop dying your
eyebrows dude
stop dying your eyebrows especially
you're worth whatever billions of
dollars you don't have to do that man
there's not enough people around them go
don't dye the eyebrows the mustache if
you have to shave down don't do that
unless you're Michael Jordan you can't
do that dude you can't do that
he's like I'm worth five billion dollars
I'm like you can do that
so when Jose Aldo so I don't know if you
know he won the he didn't win it was a
majority draw against him and Jeremy
Stevens
or Jeremy Stevens and then since that
bout happened Conor McGregor tweeted me
and Aldo should box and then you know I
don't know we talked about it before
there's an article where yeah
cool match up and you know we needed him
and I love him that's my brother but
after this son of a [__] [__] he's
like yeah [__] see that's just him
looking for a fight again these are
feeder leaks for those big boxing yeah
that's all it is and then this is also
what he said to Jeremy Cruz he only
talks now because he has a fight book
and does so to sell anything not to
actually fight he's a son of a [__]
yeah that's fair yeah and then Conor
McGregor replied with this who pissing
your outside yeah
okay then whatever lad I was only trying
to be nice who pissing your acai that's
funny and then uh he also tweeted this
last thing here man who the [__] is that
guy should box which is interesting
hilarious yeah yeah that's all this is
feeders into that and then real quick to
end this part I didn't get this I saw
this who is that chick that's Conor
McGregor's mom I guess this is a while
ago Conor McGregor's mom said hi ho and
they took a picture together and he's
supposed to just put the picture in this
post did his mom ask for this pick
that's what Jeremy Stevens says about
who knows what happened I don't know
well why would he ask for a pic with
Connor's mom
pictures
Jimmy Stevens hilarious
but he goes yeah your brittle bones
ready to throw heat name the place in
time you can have the steroids because I
know you got wobbly legs in late rounds
hmm
yeah yeah
um
oh this one's was kind of weird too so
this is Conor McGregor talking about
just engaging because Justin Gates you
said he'll retire if yeah
which is weird yeah and then so the
Connor just replied with this that brain
dead fool got tile shut off one single
win and was versus Chandler yet he will
quit and retire if I get the same thing
classic gaichi bird brain Jackass 2
title attempt no wins yeah that was
pretty much it yeah
yeah
all right uh this is we talked about
Patty people last week about him doing
the surgery he just he just finished the
surgery and he's calling out Jared
Gordon again to do a rematch and then
this is Jared Gordon's response
uh funny thing is going in the fight I
had ankle injury as well documents yes
but you'll see I couldn't walk for weeks
after I fight too I get why he's angry
he knows that one like the rest of the
world
yeah so I wonder if uh Gordon even wants
that fight he doesn't he said he has
bigger yeah I think they need to move on
but also let's say they did make that
fight for whatever reason I don't think
they should let's say they made that
fight is that a main event in London no
I don't think so right it's not I don't
see anyone vying for that [__] fight
like we have to see it again I think
they both need to move on but I remember
someone
some sort of MMA person said that uh
this is smart by Patty because you know
Gordon was a big oh not big but it was a
jump up in competition and he realized
he couldn't really beat him so he's like
fight him again versus someone even
higher now
so that might be like a strategic thing
with uh you need to slow down on them he
still needs to develop because he's his
his star Powers outshine his experience
yeah so they need to
hopefully that humbled him even though
he had surgery and stuff hope he's
working on his skills which I'm sure he
is but yeah there's a lot of guys where
their star out shines their their talent
um this is about two about announcements
for Bellator 297 it's uh Vadim namkov
who's a killer versus yo Romero and then
Sergio Perez versus Patricio Pitbull
someone I have this group chat with a
bunch of guys you would know and someone
sent me this uh video it says it shows
uh Joel Romel running says uh why does
Joel look like he has uh rods in his he
runs so stiff like he has rods in his
neck are back like that's because he
does and he's literally like he can't
he's just running straight up he just
seems so dense and yeah
yeah nemcob versus Romero is a great
fight I'll take namcov in that fight
though cool and we haven't heard from
your boy Brian Ortega in a while but um
I guess he's responding to Elio to purya
who just be uh he beat Bryce Mitchell
pretty badly not too long ago yeah you
look fantastic yeah but also uh Brian
doesn't want the fight he said he said
in this league you don't get to my level
with your mouth like you had to win some
fights exactly see pretty much know this
article he was so taprine was calling up
Ortega Ortega's like you know first of
all he's injured he's still you know
recovering from his shoulder injury so
he can't fight anyways and then uh yeah
he should get to the top position before
calling out Ortega but he'd definitely
fought him if he was okay but once
they're on their way up to where I'm at
then you can come and join him but you
can't use your mouth to come up here you
know this is the fighting world can only
do so much with the mouth and this time
uh is you're gonna have to fight I know
he has a fight lined up good for him and
after if he earns his way up then let's
do it yeah that's the right way to do
that and the fine lineup Joshua holy
[__] yeah five round headliner god dog
so I think obviously if he beats Josh
Emmett then he's definitely in the yeah
yeah then Brian Ortega's next and then
title shot Jesus they put him on the
fast track but boy did he look good
didn't he yeah
and Josh Emmett [__] man it's a great
fight if I'm Emin I'm like I guess I'll
take that fight that sucks forever yeah
I know it's like I guess I want that
all right so the uh pfl's senior vice
president
Lauren Mack said that Jake Paul will
definitely have his first or his only
MMA fight in the organization by the end
of this year
feel better who depends who he's gonna
fight right a bit a big number for pfl
but to do what he's doing boxing like
that takes all your attention and
efforts to go away from that and focus
on MMA you know depends what you want to
do I think by him going over to MMA
shows us that he you know he knows that
he's just gonna take these money fights
I don't he his goal is not to be a world
champion boxing he there's you can't do
both you can't you can't he's already
behind the ball he's already behind the
eight ball unboxing he lost Tommy Fury
now you can focus on MMA so he's just
doing these big payday fights good for
him it's exactly what he should be doing
and uh one more on Jake Paul so I guess
one of his training partners for boxing
uh was this guy Marcus Perez who was in
the UFC for a little bit
and uh I guess he was supposed to be
paid 300 bucks to spar Jake Paul and
Jake Paul didn't pay him because he was
being I don't know like a kind of a you
know a taunting kind of guy and he was
beating him up and all that stuff but
then eventually he never ended up paying
him
so he said uh I think that's because
others were cool uh they told me they
went all right not with me my session
ended in a fight his quartermen wanted
to enter the ring and get me started
trying to punch the back of my head
because I started taunting him he got
mad he's not used to this I started uh
showboating keeping my hands low I
dropped him with a body punch he got mad
so I punched him in the nose and drew
blood he got desperate interesting yeah
I don't know how true this is but that's
what he's claiming but you never know
either like here's the other thing you
know trust me this [__] it falls
from the top Jake Paul's probably not
running his finances to paying spawn
Partners probably one of his coaches has
nothing to do I bet Jake's I can't pay
not just communication I bet even now
Jake's like yeah pay the [__] I don't
need this you know
um
I won't play this clip because I wonder
if we can but it's basically Logan Paul
is saying that he'd want to fight Tyson
Fury and MMA obviously he said if you
get punched he'd be destroyed but he's
like it's you know he could just take
him down and destroy him on the ground
uh yeah I don't like that for Logan you
know don't get me wrong the kid has more
wrestling experience than Tyson but
you're talking about the greatest
heavyweight to ever do it with great
footwork and it was you know the
comments are right there they said
Logan's act he wrestling High School
acts like he's Beau nickel or something
yeah I agree you know the wrestling
pedigree I don't think is enough to to
beat Tyson Fury in any form of Combat
Sports you know
oh there you go
uh this is a quick interesting one so
Benson Henderson you know how he always
puts toothpicks in his mouth right when
he fights and everything I guess there's
one time that he he actually swallowed
the toothpick yeah he's trying to scare
his mom yeah like coming downstairs
because he he just graduated he wanted
to surprise her and then he ended up
swallowing the toothpick
and then
it doesn't say what happened as far as
like he didn't go to the hospital or
anything I guess he just literally
swallowed the toothpick and goes I have
no I've had no complications since so
apparently he actually swallowed a
toothpick but he's all right he's all
right and that I actually Googled and
what could happen and apparently it
could you know Pierce and stuff and you
can't digest
so it's probably past it maybe it just
stuck somewhere and just whatever I
don't know
um another quick one so remember below
balam Muhammad
uh met up with Dana White here's a
picture of him they said that a great
talk or whatever everything was good
this is after the whole Colby Covington
conspiracy thing with you know Leon
Edwards
but now below saying that he's only
interested in either Edwards Kamara
Usman or Covington next what's up what
about uh
so even though the UFC wants it even
Dana Watts said it he's going to do
shotgun next he's saying he's only
interested in uh Edwards Usman or Colby
Kobe and this is after they met up with
yeah you know what well Kobe's fighting
Leon we know that Camaro who knows how
long he is off so I guess I'll wait for
tomorrow so tomorrow versus Muhammad
yeah so I guess that I mean to be fair
too Muhammad deserves that 100
absolutely I don't like the the Shopkins
it's crazy he's he's past that yeah
you shouldn't have to fight this young
line coming up like he's already earned
his chops
all right here's another real quick one
Dustin Poirier he's going to be on the
commentary team for UFC 287 on the desk
as a desk analyst oh sweet yeah yeah
he's great good for Dustin
I wonder who's replacing
I don't know they is it like is he
placed replacing Dominic or business
they usually have Biz being on the desk
up there if they're not working the
fights yeah and sometimes Anthony Smith
like there's Anthony Smith uh Rashad
sometimes too sometimes we're shot yeah
yeah Karen Bryan
this one I thought was trippy because
the reason why I found this article
because it was related to the UFC but I
guess there's this female pro wrestler
um her name is She-Hulk or something
like that she went to a
the UFC San Antonio which was you know
Cheeto Vera in San Diego and then she
was staying with one of her friends
and then apparently at 4am
so she said like some guy's gonna come
pick me up I'm gonna go with him because
he's gonna introduce me to people from
the UFC
and then she went missing I am yeah
super weird she went missing
for an entire week her friend was trying
to get a hold of her okay and then
suddenly
she was found a week later in downtown
somewhere in Austin I think okay by the
police and all it says is some guy
called you took you had her phone and
called her friend said like I have your
you know your friend's phone I took it
from her and literally that's the only
thing that I could hear she's returned
home now but that's the only thing on
the story anything no
literally that's it did she meet with
UFC at 4am he didn't say [__] it's other
than her mom is happy that she's home
now but it's super weird God dang yeah
anyway yeah that's that's interesting
what's up that's intense yeah hopefully
she's all right Jesus Christ wonder what
they did
oh we're pay attention to the thick Boy
Instagram because they're doing a uh q a
on there so submit your questions for
UFC 287 or whatever matchups you want to
talk about uh we'll air that on Thursday
I'll be answering your questions
get them in by Wednesday and it'll be on
the thick boy uh Instagram
I guess we'll just finish off on this
one I remember I thought this was a joke
it's not going to happen
for sure yeah so Rampage Jackson and Bob
Sapp they did a fight circus and I mean
if you watch the clip and I'm not sure
it's on Twitter so I think we can but if
you watch this clip you can tell they're
just taking it easy it's just like
It's just tough to do head moving not
hit your buddy God Rampage just rocking
him with this [__] hook but I mean
rapping could destroy these guys who are
these two
you think to type into PornHub I think
they're like a
a radio team or something like that
they're lucky rampaging but oh uppercut
by Road page
Bob sap barely touching them yeah
so it was kind of silly but they
actually went through with it looks like
they had fun though fight circus yeah
all right that's pretty much it all
right kids well that's it here you got
my picks for UFC 287 enjoy the fight
card come watch it with me Brian Callan
Cheeto Vera and a very special guest
live 7 P.M thick boy YouTube Calabasas
fight campaign for UFC 287 uh on the
docket for tour wise uh next week I'm in
Atlanta that's Atlanta Georgia at the
punch line April 13th through the 15th
Atlanta Georgia and then June 2nd
through the 4th La Jolla comedy store
that's right outside San Diego so that's
uh June 2nd through the 4th The Comedy
Store in La Jolla and then after that
I'm off to Europe Belfast Glasgow
Manchester London Cardiff Dublin is June
25th so come get you some you're up all
right uh tickets at thick boy.com tiger
stick whiskey across the board 59.99
getthickboy.com that's it kids tune in
to the Cowboys fight companion this
Saturday UFC 287 come watch it with me
of the fight campaign with Cheeto Vera
Brian count very special guest which
I'll announce on Thursday and myself
will be there live for UFC 287 on thick
boy YouTube alright love you guys be
nice to each other Atlanta see you next
week I'm out if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding